first tonight at 11 a scary situation
caught on camera an suv carrying a group
of people flipped in the middle of a
busy intersection on the las vegas strip
those people you can see trapped inside
there good evening and thank you so much
for joining us tonight i'm sasha loftis
this caused a lot of chaos as dozens
jumped into action to help those who
were stuck inside madison kimbrough is
live on the strip tonight with details
on this madison
[Music]
yeah it happened on tuesday right here
on flamingo and las vegas boulevard a
very busy intersection and in the video
you're about to see it shows just how
bad of a crash it could have been take a
look
an suv flipped in the middle of traffic
on the strip tuesday afternoon trapping
a family inside as onlookers tried to
help by kicking in and hitting the
windshield richard kelly who took the
video says he works just a couple blocks
away and heard the loud bang we tried to
push the truck over at first before i
started recording the video we couldn't
because it was sliding
at that time i started recording because
a lot of people came out and they
started
breaking stuff to try and get them out
you can see as the family makes their
way out of the suv through a sunroof
that was pulled off everyone survived
but many looks of disbelief and shock as
they make their way back to safety
holding on to their children and
checking if everyone is okay i believe i
seen a husband and a wife
a younger child
that would use a car seat
and
two or three other kids like 10 between
10 and 13 years old according to a man
in the video the suv flipped after
running a red light and sideswiping his
car he and his sister were said to be
okay it's unknown if there were any
major injuries reported afterwards kelly
acknowledging the severity of the
incident as a crash like this puts a lot
into perspective people need to take
their time and be grateful with their
family when they have them because
anything could change in a heartbeat
we reached out to metro to see if there
was an accident report filed we are
waiting to hear back reporting live on
the strip tonight madison kimbrough live
local now